we're told that triangles let's see you
have triangle PQR and triangle ABC are
congruent the side length of each square
on the grid is one unit so each of these
is one unit which of the following
sequences of transformations Maps
triangle PQR on to triangle ABC so we
have four different sequences of
transformations and so why don't you
pause this video and figure out which of
these actually does map triangle PQR so
this is PQR onto a b c and it could be
more than one of these so pause this
video and have a go with that alright
now let's do this together so let's
first think about sequence a and I will
do sequence a in this purple color so
remember we're starting with triangle
PQR so first it says a rotation 90
degrees about the point about the point
R so let's do that and then we'll do the
rest of this sequence so if we rotate
this 90 degrees so one way to think
about it is a line like that is then
going to be like that so we're going to
go like that and so R is going to stay
where it is you're rotating about it but
P is now going to be right over here one
way to think about it is to go from R to
P we went down 1 and 3 to the right now
when you do the rotation you're going to
go to the right one and then up 3 so P
is going to be there and you could see
that that's the rotation so that side
will look like this so that is P and
then Q is going to go right over here
it's going to do once again also do a 90
degree rotation about R and so after you
do the 90 degree rotation P Q R is going
to look like this so that is Q so we've
done that first part then a translation
six units to the left and seven units up
so each of these points are going to go
six units to the left and seven up so if
we take a point P six to the left one
two three four five six seven units up
one two three four five six seven it'll
put it right over there so that is point
P if we take point R we take six units
to the left one two three four five six
seven up one two three four five six
seven it gets us right over there
and then point Q we goes six units to
the left one two three four five six
seven up is one two three four five six
seven puts us right over there so this
looks like it worked
sequence a is good it is it Trant it
maps PQ R on to ABC this last one isn't
an R this is a Q right over here so that
worked sequence a now let's work on
sequence beat up this in different color
a translation eight units to the left
and three up so let's do that first so
if we take point Q 8 to the left and 3
up 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 3 up 1 2 3 so this
will be my red Q for now and now if I do
this point are 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
let me make sure I do that right 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 3 up 1 2 3 so my new R is going
to be there and then last but not least
Point P 8 to the left 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 3
up 1 2 3 goes right there so just that
translation will get us to this point
it'll get us to that point so we're
clearly not done mapping yet but there's
more transformation to be done so it
looks something like that
since then a reflection over the
horizontal line through point a so point
a is right over here the horizontal line
is right like that so if I were to
reflect point a wouldn't change point R
right now is three below that horizontal
line point R will then be three above
that horizontal line so point R will
then go right over there just from that
I can see that this sequence of
transformations is not going to work
it's putting are in the wrong place so
I'm going to rule out sequence B
sequence C let me do that with another
color I don't know I will do it with
this orange color a reflection over the
vertical point through point Q I'm sorry
a reflection over the vertical line
through point Q so let me do that so the
vertical line through point Q looks like
this you can draw that vertical line so
if you reflect it Q is going to be it's
going to stay in place
R is one to the right of that so now
it's going to be one to the left once
you do the reflection and point P is
four to the right so now it's going to
be four to the left one two three four
so P is going to be there after the
reflection and so it's going to look
something like this after that first
transformation I know it's getting a
little bit messy but this is what you
probably have to go through as well so
I'll go through it with you all right so
we did that first part the reflection
then a translation for to the left and
seven units up so four to the left and
seven up so let me try that so four to
the left one two three four seven up one
two three four five six seven so it's
putting Q right over here I'm already
suspicious of it because sequence a
worked where we put P right over there
so I'm already suspicious of this but
let's keep trying so four to the left
and seven up 1 2 3 4 7 up 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
so R is going to the same place that
sequence a put it and then point P 1 2 3
4
one two three four five six seven
actually it worked so and it works
because this is actually an isosceles
triangle so this one actually worked out
we were able to map a PQR onto ABC with
sequence C so I like I like this one as
well and then last but not least let's
try sequence D I'll do that in black so
that we can see it so first we do a
translation eight units to the left
and three up eight to the left and three
up so we start here one two three four
five six seven eight three up one two
three so I'll put my black cue right
over there so 8 to the left 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 3 up 1 2 3 I'll put my black are
right over there that's actually exactly
what we did in sequence B the first time
so P is going to show up right over
there so after that translation sequence
that first translation in sequence D it
gets us right over there then it says a
rotation negative 270 degrees about
point a so this is point a right over
here and negative 270 degrees that's
negative so it's going to go clockwise
and C 180 degrees let's say if we were
to take this line right over here if we
were to go 180 degrees it would go to
this line like that and then if we go to
another 90 degrees it actually does look
like it would it would map on to that so
this is actually looking pretty good if
you were to this line right over here
well then if you go negative 270 degrees
we'll map on to this right over here and
then that point R will kind of go along
for the ride is one way to think about
it and so it'll go right over there as
well so I'm actually liking sequence D
as well so all of these work except for
sequence B